(uptempo techno music)
- Welcome to a Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is John Yoo,
who is Professor of Law
at the University of California Berkeley,
Boalt School of Law.
He's the author of The
Powers of War and Peace,
and War By Other Means:
An Insider's Account
of the War on Terror.
John, welcome to the program.
- Thanks for having me.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Seoul, South Korea,
and was raised in the Philadelphia area.
So, I came over here
from the United States,
to the United States when
I was three months old.
Initially grew up in southern New Jersey
then grew up ultimately in
the Philadelphia suburbs.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well, there's a lot of different ways.
One, they were immigrants
from another country.
I think that was very important to me,
the idea that you would leave the country
you grew up in and went to school in,
and go to an entirely different country,
something I think is very hard
for Americans to understand,
there's not a lot of immigration
from America to other countries,
so I think that's one
thing is that how strong
the pull of the United States is
on people in other countries.
Second thing is, you know,
I think they fled military
dictatorship, at the time.
South Korea in the 1960s and in the 1970s
was a military dictatorship.
And so, there's a big contrast I think,
between there and the kind of
political, and economic, and
social freedoms one has here.
And the third one, obviously, Korea is
a divided country to this day,
and there's this famous shot from space
of the Korea peninsula at night.
And you can see the northern
half is completely black.
And the southern half is full of light,
as is the Western world.
And so, one of the last
thing I got from my parents,
I think, was their deep
suspicion of communism,
and the Soviet Union,
And because of that, more
sympathy, and you know,
when I got older in the
American political system,
of people who did not
think that the communists
were gonna win or were a
legitimate political system.
And that fighting expansion
of the Soviet Union
was a good thing.
- Mm-hmm.
Was there a discussion
of politics, the law,
around the dinner table?
- No, I'm sorry, I don't have
one of those great
stories growing up where
my parents are cross-examining the kids
about politics and who to vote for.
In fact, both, all I know about
my parents' political views
is that one of them is a Republican
and one of them is a Democrat
but I'm not sure which one is which,
and they've never told me, so
we didn't talk a lot about,
partisan or party politics
at the table at all.
You know, so I can't,
I can't say that my views were shaped
at the dinner table, or
my skills as a lawyer
was shaped from arguing
with my parents and sibling
about politics and law.
- Where did you do your undergraduate work
and then your law degree?
- I went to Harvard College
and I majored in history,
American diplomatic history in particular.
I wrote my undergraduate thesis
about efforts to cooperate in
the sharing of nuclear weapons
between the United States and
Western Europe in the 1960s.
And I did my Law Degree at Yale
where, we don't have majors in law school
but I worked primarily in
the fields I still do now,
constitutional law and
international affairs.
- And when where you
bitten by bug to look at
foreign policy, international law,
the power of the president,
those set of things that
run throughout your work?
- Actually it comes all
the way from middle school.
Well part of it is just,
having come from Korea,
being an immigrant,
and coming from a place where
the United States fought,
and drew in one of its Cold War battles.
So that story of course, would make me
sort of interested in the beginning.
The second thing is I went to a school,
in middle school and high school
that heavily emphasized
Western civilization
and the study of the classics.
So I read a lot about Greek and
Roman sources and histories,
which are, a lot of it is about
what we would think of today
as foreign affairs, politics,
military and so on.
And so I was interested even
before I got to college,
and then when I got to
college I got to study
a lot different aspects
of international relations
as it interacted with the
American domestic system.
And then, law school, certainly
more finely narrowed that down
to really the legal aspects of that.
- And did you have any professors either
as an undergraduate or at law school
who heavily influenced you?
- Yes, in college I was
heavily influenced by two professors who,
and it's probably the
normal course at Harvard,
neither of them are there anymore and,
one was Thomas Schwartz,
who's a professor of history,
at Vanderbilt who was a real student
of the German reconstruction
period after World War II
and is just last, I think two years ago
came out with this book about
Lyndon Johnson in Europe.
The other professor I was
close to was Brian Ballou
who's a professor of history at Virginia
and he was a student of the
American administrative state.
So actually if you think
about those two interests
that actually combined
from those two areas.
And law school, I was or
the people I was closest to,
Peter Schuck, who's been
many times to UC Berkeley,
probably be back again,
student of administrative law,
Harrold Kohs, say foreign
affairs and Akila Marr
who really studied constitution from
an originalist perspective and so again,
all three of those are,
continue to be influences
on my work today.
- How were you affected
by the Reagan revolution,
or were you?
- You know, given the kind of
millue I think I came out of
I was very supportive of
President Reagan's policies,
particularly in foreign affairs.
The idea that the Soviet
Union was an evil empire,
it was an evil system
and the United States
was appropriately trying to defeat it,
not just reach some state
of coexistence with it,
but to actually win in the Cold
War is very attractive to me
and he, Carter was really the president
I was really conscious of.
There's a sharp difference between the two
and I really though Reagan had
foreign policy about right.
Domestic policy, I sort of like the idea
of lower tax cuts.
I mean more tax cuts, lower government
intervention in society.
More space for private activity.
People sometimes find it odd that I'm a
libertarian when it comes
to domestic social issues
as opposed to foreign affairs.
However, Reagan did not cut spending,
which he should have done.
But other than that, the
other aspects of his policy
I thought were, I very much agreed with.
- In one of the books or
one of the articles I read,
it mentioned that you,
the federalist society,
that you joined that when
there were only eight members
and it was made up of
conservatives and libertarians,
I think it said.
So there is this dycotomy
in the conservative,
in what we came to think of
as the conservative movement
and also in your own thinking.
- Oh yeah, there is, I
mean people maybe generally
don't realize it but
within what's thought of
as the conservative legal movement,
there's a deep division
between libertarians
who are just relatively suspicious
of government power on any form.
No matter what level of government it is.
And I would think of as
more social conservatives
or big government
conservatives, which also
runs through the Republican Party too.
And there's no resolution of it.
And one thing the federal
society is good about
is that it provides a forum to those two
groups to debate things.
One great issue that they debate about
and disagree about is
wire tapping, for example.
The war on terrorism,
so there's not unified
view amongst legal conservatives.
- During this formative
experience there was
a lot of energy in the
conservative movement.
It was an exciting time
to become a conservative.
That's fair, isn't it?
- Yeah, I mean I think, it's interesting.
The dominant sort of,
the dominant way of thought at that time
was still, I think fairly
liberal and so if you
were a conservative,
particularly the place
like Harvard or Yale
or any major university
at that time, conservatives
were sort of more
the radicals, I guess they were.
They were trying to overturn the way
things had been going for some time.
So yeah it was more exciting.
The people involved were maybe younger.
They had the fresher and newer ideas.
They were more fun to debate about them,
whereas what I think of
as a liberal orthodox
either had really been a
product of the new deal.
And then Roosevelt and Johnson and Carter
seemed tired and defensive.
- Mh-mmm.
You've been fortunate to have a number
of legal mentors, Judge Silverman first.
Then Justice Thomas.
And then you also worked for Orin Hetch.
Talk a little about each of them briefly
and how they influenced
you because they really
gave you a view of
national security issues,
conservative legal scholarship,
and then finally the
view from the congress.
- I learned a great deal
from all three of them.
They've all been very
influential mentors of mine.
Judge Silverman is the first
person I had a real job under.
You serve as a law
clerk which means you're
their assistant, you help
the judge research cases.
If they want you to find what the laws
of some subject you go find it.
You help them prepare for oral arguments.
You basically,
research assistant, basically.
In a way, professors have them.
And he was a really good for me because he
was someone who combined those
things I was interested in.
He had been an ambassador.
He was ambassador to Ugoslavia.
And he's continued to be a
figure in foreign affairs
and national security even
though he's a judge and a lawyer.
He's not a pure policy person.
But someone who trained in law.
So even just a few years
ago he was the joint
chairman on the president's commission
on the WMD in Iraq study.
So he continues to play a role.
So that was very,
that was very important to me to see that
the things I was interested
in could lead to a career.
And to see how he thought things through.
He was the first real lawyer I worked for.
Justice Thomas is also very
influential person in the way I thought,
or the way I think.
He taught me a number of things.
One thing he taught me was not to really
worry so much about criticism.
He really thinks the key thing in any
of these things we do is
to reach what you think
is the right answer.
And if you think it's the right answer,
then defend it.
And not to be so swayed by criticism.
Not that you don't pay attention to what
other people's arguments and views are,
but you consider them
all and then you make
your decision and then you live with it.
You don't sway back and
forth based on criticism.
And so he's been criticized a lot.
He's one of the most
criticized public figures.
And I think what I saw
was a person who continued
to do his job and continued to stand up
for what he believed in.
Senator Hatch, again I
was very lucky, again
to work for a wonderful guy
and someone who taught me
about how politics works.
So what I've always often
said to students is that
we can prepare you in law school how
to be a judicial clerk.
I think you can be prepared in law school
or graduate school how to
work in the executive branch.
And I don't think in, no
offense to political scientistt
or to lawyers, I don't
think we have a clue
how to teach people how
to work in congress.
You can't have a class on congress 101
that really tells you what a lobbyist does
and how you would do it.
How you would be a staffer.
How you work things through the political
process in congress.
What are hearings really like?
How do you run?
So of all the jobs I've actually had
I think I learned the
most from Senator Hatch
in that one year I worked for him
because there's no way right now we can
effectively teach that
experience in the classroom.
- Which leads me to my next question.
What do you think it takes
to do the kind of law
that you do, it's not tort law.
It's not contracts.
It's really sort of the
constitution international
relations, it's a very
hard thing to get your hands on, my view.
- In the law school what they would say,
it's a hard thing to bill hours for.
In the sense that
- You don't work
for government.
- You obviously make money.
There's no law firms that have a practice
in foreign affairs law.
- That's it.
So what does it take to do that?
Idealism, I guess?
- Well first of all, I think you're not
gonna make a lot of money if you go
into that kind of work
and most of the work
is in the government.
You get into corporate,
to extent, companies
might get involved in it.
It's really to extent their
multinational companies
and they run across issues,
but really the things
I'm concerned about war powers,
treaty powers and so on,
don't really rise that
much in private practice.
So the only real way
to get experience in it
and to learn about it is by doing it.
So I've had the opportunity to work
in all three branches of the government
and to see these kinds of issues
from each of those different perspectives.
And there's a lot of jobs, not a lot,
but there are good number
of jobs in the government,
in the federal government that involve
these kinds of issues, but outside of that
there really isn't much.
So it's hard for me to tell students
to go into this as a line of work.
I mean we can teach them
the issues in the class,
but it's gonna be very
hard to get actual jobs
where you work on this everyday.
- Let's talk now to
where you found yourself
at the time of 9/11
because as I was preparing
for this interview, it struck
me that you were present
at the Creation in a way.
And you were in the Bush administration.
You had a position at Berkeley
and you were on leave.
So in the summer of 2001,
what was the position
you took up and what
does that position do?
- So I was in the office of legal counsel.
I was a deputy in the
office of legal counsel.
That office functions
to provide legal advice,
constitutional issues mostly,
but also statuatory issues
to the executive branch
because many people in the public world
don't really realize it, but the courts
only end up interpreting a fairly small
proportion of the law.
The executive branch
has to enforce the law
and when it does that it has to figure out
what the law means in the first place.
So the office of legal
counsel functions as sort of
the office within the entire government
that is a court of final appeal
to those kinds of questions
within the presidency
and the agencies.
And also serves to serve
a advisor on the law
to the president and the white house.
I was hired to be in charge
of the foreign affairs
docket within that office.
It's a very small office, only has about
20 to 30 people in it.
If you go back to that
world, the pre 9/11 world,
this was not and
administration that was gonna
place a lot of importance or
emphasis on foreign affairs.
It was emphasizing tax cuts
and faith based initiatives
and so on, so it wasn't
thought that this was
going to a particularly
important or heavy job.
There weren't I think a
great number of national
security specialists in the administration
or in the justice department.
So at 9/11 I was on my desk.
I think was working on fairly
mundane routine things.
So I was at my desk and I saw the second,
on television I saw the second plane
hit the world trade center towers.
And I stayed there.
I remember Washington was evacuated
which was an incredible sight.
Since I worked on these
issues I had to stay
and I stayed there probably until
two or three in the morning.
But it was very strange experience.
To go out and get
something to eat for lunch,
I couldn't find anything.
Washington was a ghost town.
It was completely empty.
All the stores were shut.
And driving home that night
was an incredible sight
because, I never thought I
would see in our lifetime,
I drove over the 14th street bridge,
which is the main bridge leading out of
Washington to Virginia, where I lived.
And it goes right by the
Pentagon and you drove by
and the night sky is
lit up by the huge fire
at the Pentagon.
I never thought I'd live to see the day
where part of our capital is on fire.
- Did you realize right away how important
the research that you had been doing was?
Because I believe, and let
me show this first book
of yours, which I guess
actually is the second
book to come out, I'm not sure.
- [John] First one.
- The first, The Powers of War.
You were working on this
book before you went
to Washington, right.
So you were, and in
this book you're really
grappling with a new interpretation
of what are the powers of the president.
- Yeah, during the '90s, my primary
scholarly activity was
this war powers question.
One would have been
debating since well before
the Vietnam war, but
Vietnam War was really
when it became most prominent was the
does the president have
the authority to use
force abroad without
congress' authorization,
without declaration of war
or any other kind of authorization.
And you're right, I
think what I had to argue
was new in the sense
that most legal scholars,
and the prominent ones at this time,
and probably continue
to today still think--
- And Harold Koh is one of them.
One of your teachers.
- Was probably one of the
leading people in this,
takes this position.
Or the view that president
acts on constitutionally
unless he or she gets the
permission of congress
through declaration of war or a statute
to wage a war abroad.
I started working on that in 1993,
was when I first started doing it.
And you know, the '90s
were a period when no
one though there would be any wars anymore
and this would be kind of a back water
of constitutional work.
The other thing I just point out is
this is an area where
the practice is very much
at odds with the academic consencus.
You look at certainly since
World War two, if not before
in several wars, some
very significant ones
like Korea itself, which didn't have
any kind of congressional authorization.
So yeah, this is something I
was working on before 9/11.
I believed I had signed
the contract to publish
this book before I went
off into government.
I had not planned to go
into government in 2001.
So I had planned, this
book would have probably
come out in 2002.
- And in doing your
theory you're essentially
in the book, let's talk
briefly about that.
You're looking at the record of practice,
the imperatives of a dangerous world,
and the structural advantages
of the executive branch.
Those are the three things
that you're identifying
as truly important.
And when you did that when
you brought what I guess,
one would call a conservative perspective
or a new way of thinking, which
is or is not conservative,
you essentially came up with an argument
about the president's
power and the congress.
What is that argument?
- Well first let me say
this isn't a really,
in my view, a conservative
versus liberal view
in the sense that
President Franklin
Roosevelt certainly I think
would have agreed with me
and republicans at that time
were quite critical of Roosevelt or Truman
and a republican congress or Johnson.
So I don't really think it follows
a conservative level thing.
Historically, although
it certainly does now.
So the basic view is this, I don't think
the constitution and
the area of war powers
is so straight jacketed that it requires
a step by step process.
Like a dual key launch
system on a submarine,
where the president can't turn his key
until congress has turned his key
and that this is all set
out in the constitution.
Rather I think the constitution
has a flexible process,
either branch can act on its own.
Take the initiative.
Also means either branch can try to stop
the other branch using its own powers.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
That the constitutional
system actually anticipates,
if not intends there to be some conflict
between the executive
and legislative branches,
between the president and congress
over something like war.
But what I didn't think
it was was this kind of
legalistic process like passing a law.
And I think that makes sense because
that would make the most sense if you had
the other elements that you mentioned.
That you had a world that was dangerous,
you would want the
government to be able to act
flexibly and quickly if you needed to.
If future challenges
were gonna be uncertain,
you would wanna have,
again, an executive can
take the initiative
and congress can choose
to support and congress can also block him
if it wants to.
But what is so, I emphasize
constitutional flexibility,
the interesting thing
about this is the critics
of practice had always
based their arguments
in the original understanding
of the constitution
which is not a familiar home
to these kinds of scholars
in almost any other issue.
So I think what my contribution was to say
the practice that has been
going on in this country
for many, many decades is not actually
inconsistent with the original view
of the constitution.
The constitution was
originally was written
to be flexible so you
can harmonize the two.
Otherwise the view has to be that there
have been many, many
presidents over many decades
including most of our great presidents
who have been acting unconstitutionally
in all of these areas.
- When you look at the specifics
and I think this is
important in a way that
you're very clearly saying,
look if the congress
wants to stop a war, they can
cut off the funding basically.
And then on the other
hand, really the president
can just take an action and he really
doesn't need a declaration of war.
In the case of fighting Al-queida
and the case of the Iraq war,
Bush went to the congress,
but he really didn't have to do that.
- That's right.
I would say the Korean War
or any number of things.
Lincoln's response to
Civil War or as you said,
the Iraq War or war in Afghanistan.
I don't think the
president constitutionally
needed to get, or the Cosovo War,
president didn't need
to constitutionally need
to get the permission of congress.
On the other hand, only
congress could provide
the funds for any of those wars to go on.
And that in my view remains
congress' ultimate check.
So if congress really wants
to end the war in Iraq,
they can do it.
In fact, it's very easy to do it.
Don't even have to pass a law.
All they have to do is not pass anything
because military appropriations come up,
with this war, every, not just every year,
sometimes several times a year.
If congress just stopped and said,
we're not gonna vote you anything.
We're gonna sit passively
on our heels and just watch,
then the war would have to end.
- And this raises an interesting question
that really recurs throughout your work,
and that is the legal dimension
and the political dimension.
And so the political
realities are that congress
isn't gonna use that power.
Even probably if you had
a majority of democrats
in both the house and the senate.
So I guess the, I'm
curious about your sense
of your role because as
in the administration
being aware of the theories that
you had developed there really,
what is the play here between,
because you in your job you said about
writing a number of memos
based on these principles.
And I guess the important question
is how does our system
respond negatively to
actions of the president
if congress and the courts power
is so circumscribed?
- Well you know again,
I don't think the power
is circumscribed, and
so is a formal matter.
- [Harry] But it's a matter of politics.
- I would agree with you,
it's a matter of politics,
they choose not to use it.
And one point I really
try to make in the book
is that because groups
or people or institutions
don't use the powers at their hand,
doesn't mean we have to
reinterpret the constitution
itself to force them to do it.
If they don't want, the congress or court
doesn't want to try to
check the executive,
then that's their decision.
But that doesn't mean the
constitution's broken.
So just one point, so the second thing is
in terms of the being an
academic in government
I think is really our question,
well at the one hand I might say
and I think this has
been the consistent view
of the justice department
across many presidents
that I might think that the president
has the authority to respond to Al Qaeda
without any congressional permission.
On the other hand on the policy matter,
I was one of the small team that worked
with congress to get them to pass
such an authorization both with regard
to Afghanistan and Iraq.
So you're right, my
constitutional view is one thing,
but it may be politically better for the
Bush Administration to get permission
from congress or authorization
from congress anyway,
and that's what I did.
- There was an interview
you did with Front Line
and I was really struck by this quote
and I think it relates to what we're
talking about right now.
And this was something you said at the end
of the interview.
I think one of the things I did notice
in a lot of these debates
is that a lot of people
thought or wanted the law to have
already made the choice for them.
That's the thing that was
very interesting to me.
I think people in the
public and some members
of the military, the agencies, they think
that all this should
be decided by the law.
That the law really tells you exactly
how to treat enemy prisoners.
And it does when you're
fighting another nation state.
What I think made them more uncomfortable
was the newness of the concept,
the sort of radicalism of
this unprecedented enemy.
So in a way, you're sort
of admitting that you're
sort of sheepishly I think here,
that you were in a way surprised
by the impact of the
memos you were writing.
Or were you, is that a fair reach?
- I think what I was trying to say there
and what I think still is that,
what struck me is that,
with the war on terrorism,
not so much the war in Iraq which is a
sort of standard nation
state, nation state war.
But in the war on terrorism,
you had a situation where
this was a new kind of enemy.
And the conflict is different.
And people within the executive branch
were very relunctant to ask,
well really do the rules
that we have developed
for the kinds of wars we know,
wars between nation states covered by
the Geneva Conventions, do
they really apply here or not.
And people did not want to
think about that question.
Even though I think it
seemed to clear to me
and I think clear to a lot of other people
that legally the Genevan
Conventions don't apply.
That doesn't tell you,
if they don't apply, that doesn't tell you
one way or the other whether you should
apply the rules of the Geneva Conventions
as a matter of policy.
And there are people who
thought well, since it must,
we wanna follow policy therefore I have
to go back and read the law in some way
to find it to apply to
conflict with Al Qaeda.
So I think the law there is used as a way
not to make decisions.
To say oh the law has already
made this choice for us,
when I don't think it really has.
And that makes it harder.
If the law hasn't really
already made the decision
for you then it's harder to figure out
because you have to reach the
policy decision of your own
and take responsibility for it.
- Now in a democracy
what we believe is that
in an open debate and
because so many of these
memos, some of which you
authored were really secret
for quite a while, it prevented a kind of
vigorous debate so that the politics
didn't happen in the short term.
So it's an interesting conundrum here.
You get legal decisions
by you with a particular
perspective but nobody
knows about them, basically.
And because the political
debate didn't occur,
so there could be policy
made on the basis of well,
this is what the law says, but.
- I think that's a fair point
and a difficult problem.
And again, example,
this is always a problem
in war it seems to me,
but it's an even greater
problem in this war then in previous wars.
Which is when you vote
a war you have to take
measures in secret.
You have to swiftly and
secretly and decisively
in the word of the federalist papers.
That can be at odds with
the idea that you have
full robust debate over policy options.
Just take a standard
answer, was there a full
robust public debate in the United States
in 1941 and '42 about whether to emphasize
Europe over the Pacific as
the major field of battle
against the Axis Powers.
I don't think there ever really was.
You certainly didn't, until much later,
have public all the kinds of plans
and strategic thinking of
the Roosevelt Administration,
because there's obvious
harm that premature
disclosure of the information can have
in helping the enemy in a way it doesn't
when you're talking about tax
cuts or domestic spending.
And so that's basically a
problem, I think in all wars.
It's especially a problem
in this kind of conflict
because enemy's almost
acting entirely covertly.
So the kind of information
that we're dealing with
is primarily intelligence.
It's not reconicance.
It's not the kind of
methods you usually use
to gain information on the enemy
if the enemy was say Germany or Russia.
And because of that the
kinds of discussions
could have negative consequences in terms
of our ability to succeed
in fighting a covert enemy.
To give you one example
about wire tapping.
If you were to say, we
need to have a discussion
about wire tapping because we wanna tap
this kind of communication, then Al Qaeda
will respond quite quickly and stop
using that form of communication.
And this is not idol hypothesis.
In the '90s, I talk about in another book.
In the '90s, the
government got the ability
to actually intercept Osama Bin Laden's
personal cell phone calls
which I think is extraordinary.
And in the course of
a trial from the first
world trade center bombing by Al Qaeda,
I believe the government
leaked that it had
this ability, I think
probably to show eventually
that it knew it could trace back
that Osama Bin Laden had
actually ordered the bombing.
But within 24 hours,
Osama Bin Laden stopped
using that cell phone which was the only
obvious and rational thing for him to do,
and never used one again.
So they monitor our discussion,
which is easy to do through the internet
and they react fairly quickly.
- When one looks at these memos,
it's very clear that you were really
present at the creation
and that you had to
define a new set of terms in a way.
You had already written, I think,
or had thought about the problem of
weapons of mass destruction,
terrorist organization,
the whole notion of rogue states,
is kind of defining a new world.
So one of the challenges I guess you had
were to define terms such
as a terrorist organization.
What is torture?
And so talk a little about that.
Did you have clients here to help you
come up with these definitions?
That is clients within the government?
- Even before you get to those things,
the first term of definition
is whether it was war in fact,
which I think still
continues to be at root,
the basic area of disagreement
about people who criticize or agree
with the current administration's
terrorism policies.
Whether it's a war at all.
But then right, then
you have to talk about
who's really legitimately
a member of the enemy.
What force can you use against them?
How long can you detain them?
How do you try them?
How do you interrogate them?
You're right, all those questions come up
in a way they haven't come up before
because this is not a nation state
and because of the way they fight.
They don't come up abstractly so I mean,
as a professor in academic
you like to think,
oh the governments at the very beginning
thought coherently about everything
and applied basic principles throughout.
In the government, it
doesn't really work that way
and the government these
issues come up piece meal
based on specific questions of policy
or specific legal questions
that are put to you
by other agencies.
So one thing about the place I work
is that's not a proactive
agency in the sense,
we just declared on September 12th,
we have to rethink everything
and this is how we're gonna do it.
It's not really a policy making arm.
It's more of a reactive.
Other agencies had to confront these kinds
of question in the course of fighting
the war on terrorism,
came back and asked us
what our best opinion was.
And so they may lack a certain kind of
comprehensiveness or cohesiveness
from issue to issue that,
academics or scholars
or people would like but that's
because that's the nature,
the government deals with
the problems as they arise.
The other thing about government work
that was really surprising to me is how,
and I think we don't really
understand as academic
because academics we
can spend years studying
one decision made by the government.
And I think that's, so
we can collect almost,
collect immense amount of information,
rethink all the different possibilities,
the consequences and weigh them.
The thing that's very
hard to understand for us
is that in the government, the government
has to make decisions under extraordinary
pressures of time, extremely
limited information
and so it has to make a decision.
It doesn't have the
luxury of full analysis
that one would, and
war only make sit worse
because it compresses the
time and the consequences
of the wrong decision are much higher
than I think they are
for, again a question
of social policy or domestic policy.
- This question about what
was the nature of this war
and whether we were at
war seems to be pivotal
and I have never understood the notion
of a war on terror.
It's sort of like a war
on airplanes or something.
Was that a political
decision that mucks up
the legal sphere?
- Agree with what you're suggesting.
I think the war, calling
it the war on terrorism
is a rhetorical device that I think
speech writers probably came up with
the night of September 11th,
probably or September 12th.
It's very much at odds
I think with the way
we have to understand
the war as a legal matter
or a constitutional matter.
I quite agree that we
can't really be at war
with what is at base,
just a way of fighting,
it's a method of fighting, terrorism.
We couldn't be at war with comicazi.
What we are at war with has
to be an entity of some kind.
I think that's called a lot of problems
because people say,
well we don't really use
wartime methods on drugs.
We have a war on drugs
and we have a war on crim.
We have a war on poverty.
We don't use the military,
we don't use force,
we don't detain and so on.
But I think this is different.
I think we are at war
legally with Al Qaeda
and the groups that are
supporting and helping Al Qaeda
and anybody else who was
connected with the 9/11 attacks.
And I think the law can help us define
what that conflict is, but yeah,
when you say war on
terror then you're sort of
blurring that line and
I think it causes people
unnecessary concern about the steps
that the government is legitimately
and entitled to undertake.
- One of the controversies about the memos
that you wrote relates to torture.
Again, I don't know that these are,
have been released in the public domain,
but the memo that you
wrote is quoted as saying
that physical pain amounted to torture
must be equivalent in intensity
to the pain accompanying
serious physical injury
such as organ failure,
impairment of bodily function,
or even death.
For purely mental pain or
suffering to amount to torture
it must result in significant
psychological harm
of significant duration,
that is lasts for months
or for years.
These opinions, this memo became a very
controversial and I
wanna take it to actually
talk about kind of broader issues.
I'm not a constitution or
international law scholar
so what I wanna ask about is in doing
the writing of these memos,
did your philosophy about
the president's power
and how it really isn't constrained
in a time of war lead you to come up
with narrower definitions
of the particular issue or was that really
what you found in the law?
- In that case, in the
language you quoted it doesn't.
The hard thing about that
problem was that congress
prohibits torture in a criminal statute.
But it doesn't give much
definition to what torture is.
And the job of the executive
branch is try to give
some objective meaning that's not based
just one what one person
versus another person
might think it is.
We may all have very
different definitions of it.
And used unfortunately vague terms,
didn't give examples.
It didn't point to cases and so on.
It used language that
was torture is severe
physical pain or suffering
basically is about it.
And so the language
actually, you're right,
it was ones that was
drawn from other statutes
that congress had passed
where it had define
what severe physical pain or suffering.
- And it was domestic legislation.
- Yes, it was domestic legislation.
It didn't have to do with foreign affairs,
but you try to read all
of congress' statutes
coherently as one body of law.
And it was in an area about
emergency medical treatment.
But it was the only other
area of law we could find
where congress had defined.
The other thing that was
lacking is this had never
come up in American court.
So there's no interpretation of that law
by any judicial decision
which be another normal place
you would look to find some definitions.
So in all of that, what we did, I thought
was standard approaches to figure out
what a vague law or a
law of first impression
that no one's interpreted means.
And in fact we also
looked at the experience
of the Iraelis, the British.
Their courts had
interpreted the definition
between torture and non-torture too.
Later in the memo, the
view about presidential
power does come up.
Not as to the definitions,
but when we're asked
what would actually
happen if the president
had ordered interrogation method,
which people thought
actually did cross the line.
And in that circumstance,
my view was that the,
and it continues to
be, that congress can't
use the criminal law to
prevent the president
from using his constitutional authorities
to make a decision.
And that we had historically, as a country
and under the constitution,
given to the president
the control over battlefield tactics,
battlefield strategies and that congress
had never really tried
to interfere with those.
Now again, this doesn't
mean congress can't use
any of its other powers.
Funding, investigation, oversight.
Ultimately impeachment,
to constrain a president
that he or she, that
congress disagrees with.
But I don't think what it can do is say,
if the president uses one of this powers
in a way we don't like,
it's actually in violation
of the criminal law.
That actually brings me where I'm back to
a question you asked me in
the beginning about Reagan.
That was a problem I thought existed under
the Reagan Administration,
was that you had the,
what I think of as the criminalization
of policy disputes between
the president and congress.
And that's what I
thought would happen here
if such a hypothetical arose.
Now in the end it was my
view that that didn't happen,
that the president didn't in fact,
did not cross that line
so that part of the memo,
which is also heavily
criticized didn't actually
become operative, it
didn't become relevant
to the actual policies
that were later decided on.
- In your book really see
the president as preaminant
in deciding what treaties mean basically,
and even abrigating those treaties.
And you limit congress to the role
of the implementation
through domestic legislation.
And I guess, that's prelude to what I hear
in all of this, which
is that a lot of this
was very bad politics.
That wasn't your domain, but you know,
in the sense that if you
have a narrow definition
like this and it's kept
secret and then it leaks,
the response of the
international community
to what is being said and so on.
So there's a whirlwind of negativity
that's just lying in wait
to suddenly spring out.
- Harry, I completely agree with you
and I wouldn't deny that those thoughts,
I wasn't thinking about
those kinds of things.
In the sense that if someone was concerned
about the political
dimensions of these kinds
of decisions, the safest thing to do would
be to just do what we used to do
and not make any great change of policy.
If you didn't want to
get any criticism at all,
the safest thing to do would just be say
Geneva Conventions apply.
Every member of Al Qaeda is
a prisoner of war and so on.
It would be the risk
reverse political choice.
I think however, given
and maybe it requires
putting oneself back in the time of 9/11
and the media aftermath, the
pressures on the government
to stop another 9/11
attack were very high.
It's very hard to remember today,
particularly out here in
California, what it was like.
And so you have this I
think competing value
that runs against that which is
trying to take those
measures in a balanced way.
Not in an overly aggressive
way to try to make sure
another terrorist attack
like 9/11 doesn't happen.
Everyone thought there'd be
another in fairly short order
and the government has
been fairly successful
in stopping them.
But you're quite right, I
think the politics of it,
anybody could have foreseen
if they thought about it,
that yeah you're gonna take these measures
and when they become public as they all
do eventually it will be
extremely controversial
and you will suffer negative
political costs for them.
No doubt about.
- Is there a problem
here in the sense that we
haven't really thought
through a lot of these
definitions because
where these definitions,
and I'm being vague here, but this is what
we'll call the Bush response and the legal
memorandum that went with it,
that there is a notion here
of war 24/7 and if you live with that
over time then a lot of what we think
and know and appreciate about our system
doesn't seem to be operative, basically.
Intrusion on people's privacy.
The notion that power is
always balanced in our system.
So there are general views that we have,
I being a lamin, the
lamin add in our audience,
of what our system is
about that indirectly
becomes discredited
basically, by the impact
of all of this.
The notion that war is 24/7,
the president can do anything and so on.
- I would look at it a little
differently, obviously.
I would say that yes
this is a new kind of war
and it does require rethinking
of some basic concepts
and also of how we approach war,
since managing it and deciding issues
about it domestically.
It doesn't, I don't think it require,
it has this sort of the
huge political consequences
that people worry about and your question
expresses worry about, in the sense that
if you look at where
we've been since 9/11,
we have had the normal
operation, I would think,
of the political process.
We have, about to have our
second presidential election.
Several congressional elections.
I don't think there's
been any real distortion
in the political process.
You look at the work in the economy,
you look at the normal social activity.
They seem not to be that
traumatically affected
if you compare it to past wars.
So I think that's,
I kind of think of it as,
think of it in terms of
another discipline as way.
Medicine, in the sense
that what you've got to do
to fight Al Qaeda is you have to actually
be much more precise
and surgical in the way
you fight them so that you
don't affect the whole body,
the body of politic.
Whereas in previous wars you had much more
aggressive and wide ranging measures
that are taken by the government.
You compare this to World
War two, World War one,
and the Civil War and
what happened domestically
in terms of civil liberties and privacy
I think was far worse than
anything that's happened.
Today I just think people
don't remember the history
or don't study what happened
in those previous conflicts.
I quite agree, we would lose the war if we
actually took those measures
in response to terrorism today.
So the job of, I think the Mishusha's done
a much better job than
people give credit for
of fighting this war, but at the same time
trying to preserve as
much of normal piece time
civil liberties as possible.
And not really airing as
far over as say Lincoln
or Roosevelt or Wilson have.
- One sense that I was left
with in reading your books is,
and I wanna be judicious
here, but I'm kind of naive
about the way beauracracies work.
And of course you're
here at the university
so you have some familiarity with that.
- The beauracracy here is far worse
that anything that exists
in Washington, I assure you.
- But the idea that if for
example, if we look at the
example of the torture memo
and how certain clients
of your office, mainly the CIA,
well even in the military,
the kind of break downs
you witness in Iraq and having to do
with the transfer of a
limited use say in Guantanemo
to a broader war in Iraq that
was very different situation.
Talk a little about that
and is that just a problem
that lawyers have
generally as a rule maker?
- No, I think
it's, how would I put this?
I think it's difficult
because when you work
in the office of justice,
your job is interpret the law
and to say, here is the law,
here are the rules it sets.
And within those rules,
sort of like saying
here are the lines of the football field
and within those lines you play the game.
We're not gonna tell you
how you play the game,
but you can't go beyond those rules.
And what the job of that
department had traditionally been
was then to implement the rules too.
There's a separation
between interpreting the law
and developing and
prosecuting the policies
within the rules that you have set out.
And so to extent there is any kind of
problem in implementation.
I think your question is,
well you may have decided
these policies and they
may have made sense
in the abstract, you didn't take account
of the fact that there
are gonna be problems
in the implementation, that
people will violate the rules
or they'll go too far.
And again, this is not
unusual in the sense
that if you compare it
to domestic society,
we have very clear rules
about what police can do.
We have thousands of cases
every year in the federal
court system and the
state court system about
police who go too far.
Or prison guards who go too far.
And it is a problem,
but how do you make sure
that those agents of the
government follow the rules
and how do create a
system to correct errors.
And so thinking about now
the sir my scholars hat
on I suppose your
question can be translated
into this idea, well
you did not anticipate
how high the errors would be.
And you would have to think about,
well what would the system
to correct those errors
look like and how much would it cost.
And what's the benefit of
following the rules you set out.
We have errors, we have
errors in beauracratic systems
in the United States, in
the university all the time.
But there are costs we live with in order
to get the benefits or whatever it is.
So those are all variables I think of.
I have to say in the
writing on these issues,
that really isn't something
the memos were about
or designed to do.
And in some ways as a lawyer,
would not have been my job.
I would've been going
too far if I had said,
here I'm interpreting this law,
but here are these other things
you better be worried about.
It wouldn't be part of
the job of that office.
It might be advice one could give,
but doesn't have anything to do with a law
and my view wouldn't
be entitled to any kind
of special value as opposed to anyone else
in the governments on those issues.
In fact, I might be someone
who's less qualified
to advise someone about that
because my specialization
is just interpreting law
here and not figuring out
how do you actually now
make it work in practice.
- You wrote in this book,
the War by Other Means,
which I guess I should show,
I never showed our audience,
which is an account of your experience.
You wrote I think in the--
- My publishers, though they're different,
they all like to stick
stars on the book covers.
- I see, yeah.
You wrote upon confrontation and questions
of its policies, the Bush Administration
tended to run and hide.
I have a sense that you say,
okay this is what I think.
My scholarship tells me this.
My political inclinations.
And you would incline
more toward the airing
of these things so
there should be a debate
and that the political process would then
maybe retreat from what you
thought was the best, yeah.
- I agree.
I think the one problem,
a big problem in a lot of these
wars on terrors and issues
is it's not just that
initially there wasn't debate,
but then after a period
of time you could have
debate, obviously, and I
think the administration
ceded the field to its critics.
I think the administration
has very good reasons
for a lot of the policies
that we should, it wasn't,
but if you read the press
and follow it publicly,
you would think that these were the most
irrational arbitrary decisions just made
to agrandize the power of the president
or the vice president and I don't think
that's the case at all.
I think these are,
and I think it's an illusion
to think they're easy.
I think these are very hard questions
and there are costs and benefits to every
decision you make.
And I think the
administration just doesn't
explain itself very well or chose,
I think with the, when
the Geneva Conventions
and interrogation issue,
chose not to explain at all.
And I think only when it
came down to the wire tapping
cases did the administration
really start coming out
and explaining why it did what it did,
why it thought it could do that.
And then we also started learning later
that the executive branch was actually
secretly briefing and
consulting with members
of congress about all of these things
to try to get some kind of...
In response to one of
your previous questions,
how do you deal with this,
you have war time pressures
but have a government that's supposed to
openly disclose policy choices.
What the administration
clearly tried to do
was to not have the
information become public
so it would help the
enemy, but at the same time
try to have some kind of sort of
political consultation by secretly talking
to leaders of congress.
But I agree, that doesn't
substitute for a full
bore robust public discussion,
and I don't understand
why you wouldn't have it
once it's already become public.
But that's what they did and I think it's,
I think that's a big problem
and sort of a self inflicted wound
that the administration has suffered.
- One final question
requiring a brief answer
because we're running out
of time, but you know,
my sense of American
politics is the pendulum
swings back the other way over time.
Liberal, conservative, whatever.
Do you see that happening
here and what will
be the consequences for both the country
and actually for the people who were
involved in these decisions?
- Yeah so very interesting question.
I think after Vietnam you say
and the Nixon Administration,
you saw weakening of executive power.
The thing that's, I think, fairly striking
is that it actually lasted
fairly short period of time.
It lasted the rest of
Nixon's Administration
which under President Ford and then the
Carter Administration, one term.
And then by the Reagan
Administration you had
a lot of people in the political system
wanting a return to a vigorous executive.
So it's certainly possible
that the dissatisfaction
with the war, although
I think it's primarily
the war in Iraq and not
the war on terrorism
that's causing the great dissatisfaction,
will produce a shift away
from executive power.
But I think it's gonna
return, not because I happen
to favor it that way
or I think it's because
of complexity of the world
and foreign challenges,
and the threat of
terrorism's not going away.
And we're not gonna have
a congress manage that
day to day in the details.
It's still gonna be the job,
and always gonna be the job,
of the executive branch.
- John, I wanna thank you very
much for being with us today
and I wanna show your
two books because I think
they should be read because you are
fearless in your willingness to discuss
the issues that were raised by 9/11
and the response of this administration.
Thank you very much for
coming on our program.
- Thank you, Harry.
It's a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat music)